if you've bought virtually anything in
the last year you know that prices are
going up and it's not just in the us
either many wealthy countries are
experiencing similar trends so what's
going on here the short answer you've
probably guessed is kovid
what is going on with your mustache oh
well it was supposed to be a surprise
but with everything being so expensive i
had to
sell my mustache
but i used the money to buy you this
gold chain for your pocket watch
oh that's so ironic
why because you sold your pocket watch
to buy me a mustache comb no because i
don't have a pocket watch sorry did i
say ironic i meant weird
[Music]
around march of 2020 you may recall
people stopped going out they canceled
their vacation plans stopped going to
movies and restaurants many even stopped
going to work this led to a huge drop in
demand in many market sectors people
weren't spending nearly as much as they
usually did if you've ever run a
business you know that when demand for
your product goes down you can't just
sit around waiting for it to go back up
if you're going to survive the downturn
you have to start scaling back which is
what many companies did
factories were closed parts and
equipment sold off workers furloughed
airlines canceled flights the rental car
companies sold off huge portions of
their fleets even shipping companies
hunkered down by redrawing their
schedules to ship fewer products on more
efficient routes
it's almost like the global economy went
into low power conservation mode trying
to hibernate through the winter of covid
but the global economy is like a finicky
engine it can run fine for decades but
if you turn it off you can't just start
it back up again without problems
closing a factory is a lot easier than
reopening one you need equipment and
material from other manufacturers that
may not be reopened yet themselves and
you need to re-hire your workforce that
may not feel like going back to work yet
another thing they didn't count on was
government assistance the governments of
many wealthy countries offered generous
unemployment benefits and tax rebates to
keep their citizens afloat during the
crisis since families were spending less
savings rates skyrocketed all this meant
that when the pandemics seemed to be
waning in mid-2021 people were suddenly
ready to spend money again lots of it
and many industries were caught off
guard by the surge in demand now if you
think they should have been able to see
this coming keep in mind these are
unprecedented times the last time we had
a global pandemic this bad was the
spanish flu in the early 20th century
and the economies of the world are far
more interconnected and interdependent
than they were then
one item on a store shelf might require
components from more than a dozen
countries in the rush to get materials
and ingredients where they need to be
shipping routes and ports have become
hopelessly snarled and overcrowded and
the ongoing labor shortage means there
aren't enough dock workers and truck
drivers to unload and move at all the
result is hundreds of cargo ships just
sitting idle in ports all over the world
another unfortunate factor contributing
to inflation is extreme weather droughts
in the west are killing crops floods and
fires are disrupting transportation and
here in texas which happens to be one of
the biggest producers of plastics the
power grid was crippled by a freaky cold
snap we had last winter as a result
product packaging is still expensive and
hard to come by the upshot of all this
is too much money chasing too few goods
the classic cause of inflation by all
metrics this is the worst inflation
we've experienced in decades and while
it wasn't unexpected it has gone on
longer than anyone thought it would
there are several hidden pains of
inflation beyond sticker shock for one
because it disproportionately hits
everyday survival items like food
shelter and gas it causes outsized harm
to poorer people who spend the majority
of their income on those things second
it devalues personal savings if you've
managed to squirrel away fifteen
thousand dollars for a rainy day that
money suddenly has less purchasing power
and inflation also invites predatory
pricing as the cfo of conagra said price
adjustments are more likely to be
accepted in the market when
industry-wide and broad-based input cost
inflation occurs in other words people
are more likely to accept price hikes if
they think it's part of a widespread
trend there's already some suspicion
that the meat industry is raising their
prices above what inflation would
suggest
opec and russia are refusing to increase
oil production which would lower prices
and the shipping industry is having one
of its most profitable years ever
now before anyone panics and does
something crazy like selling their
facial hair on ebay let's look at the
positives most of the causes of this
inflation are temporary it will take
some time but manufacturing will ramp up
to meet demand supply chains will
eventually untangle and people will
spend through their savings and return
to work and most other metrics of the
economy are doing really well wages are
rising especially among low-income
workers unemployment is falling and the
stock market is booming but inflation is
one of the most psychologically painful
negative economic trends you might not
keep close track of how your ira is
doing but you are very aware that milk
costs more today than it did yesterday
even if your wages are keeping pace with
inflation it still feels like you're
getting ripped off and if people start
assuming that prices will rise
indefinitely well that's when inflation
can become a very big problem economists
call it a wage price spiral and it
occurs when enough workers start
demanding raises to compensate for price
hikes
higher wages increase the cost of
production which means higher prices
which spurs demand for more raises and
so on with seemingly no ceiling to how
high the numbers can go this does not
seem to be a danger right now but if it
becomes one there are things the federal
reserve can do to fight inflation namely
raising interest rates if it becomes
more expensive to borrow people will be
less likely to spend driving down demand
the drawback is that this also slows
down growth and our economy still has a
lot of healing to get back to where we
were before the pandemic the last thing
the fed wants to do is stifle the
recovery so what can you do
well not much there are some investments
that are considered safe during times of
inflation like tips government bonds
that match the rise and fall of
inflation real estate usually performs
well when prices go up as well however
many advisors caution against doing
anything drastic again this is an
unprecedented time and no one really
knows how financial markets will react
in the coming years no one likes higher
prices but panicking or assuming the
worst can actually exacerbate the
problem most americans though
pessimistic about the national economy
actually feel pretty good about their
own financial situation meanwhile this
bout of inflation can serve as a
reminder of how interconnected the
global economy is
instability anywhere is felt everywhere
which is reason enough for us to care
about what goes on on the other side of
the world
and that's our two cents
before you go pbs wants your feedback
right now we're running a survey to find
out what our fans like don't like and
want to see more of you can even vote on
new show ideas there's a link in the
description if you have a few minutes
we'd love to hear from you and don't
forget to tell them the two cents is
your favorite
if you want to know more about how
inflation works check out our video
something's eating your money
[Music]